okay 64 million dollar question oh my
god wow
yes
how many hot tamales did you eat during
the season the funniest part i ate so
many but the funniest part was when i
realized months in that she had never
had one and she was like what is that
i'm like you've never really
so i give her one no i'm not she
literally hated them i hate that
what you might be the feds you might be
the face who doesn't love a hot tamale
nor deny
yeah or maybe i am for eating seven
thousand hundred months not only i was
like these are so intense i was like i
don't love a gummy thing because they
get stuck in my diet that's why it's
funny that's why i chose this candy but
you but she was like like in between
takes you would eat them which is so bad
i know i hate even admitting that but
yeah i don't want this but i have plenty
of these but i'll take more
i have no problem keeping the fact that
you're
oh it's gonna happen now okay now i have
to try yeah you gotta have to get sick
curiosity come back to it come back to
it give me three people yes i do
actually i love them
i love them
but it's like a cinnamon gummy bear like
the best oh my god i want to spit this
out in my mouth so i'm not gonna do it
on camera i'm very confused by her
reaction
this is honestly i think this is the
only thing that we do not agree on it's
like the only it kills me
this is the thorn in your side i can't i
mean all right
okay
real question what would it mean you
guys to see some emmy love for this
season i mean rosie said number one you
deserve the emmy what you did this
season
bananas
it's insane
oh my god we killed kaley
if kaylee cuoco does not win an emmy for
playing five versions of herself for
eating all of these yeah i could do a
hot tamale eating contest i would win
isaac
she would i've never she's
very whatever she decides to do she
commits wholeheartedly and she's also
very fast at everything i'm very
fabulous so i feel like a hot tamale
eating contest she would a thousand
percent what i've already eaten all of
these you don't even see me do it
i do want to come back to this though
because you really did
like and you you know you were going
through some things and you just jumped
both feet in and did the damn thing
thank you listen i all that matters is
the show gets some love this has like
been my ba the show is what this is all
about and we've had some amazing
performances across the board this
season and i'm just so proud of what we
did the show as a whole i think that's
what was so excited about season one
getting the nomination was so cool but
to have the whole of the show get
recognized was like that was huge that
was really a big deal so that's what i
want okay so we saw the season finale
wild lots to unpack
lots to unpack i gotta go to a wrapping
party for that one
tied up a little bow
huh a little yes very much so i mean
thoughts expounding explanations yes
i haven't seen it yet i don't know what
happened oh come on you've seen it no we
actually both haven't watched we need to
watch it we know what happened right i
was gonna say you know what happened we
haven't watched it
okay yeah so first annie and max i mean
yeah
i was pretty it was that it was pretty
adorable that was adorable that was
pretty cool
will there ever be
than this one well listen no cuter
friendship hoping that we were gonna
read the script and we were getting
married we literally actually one of our
favorite photos that we both posted
today we made we made our own
photographer take a photo of us under
the thing and we were getting married we
were getting married i wanted that
rewrite they didn't listen to me
whatever you know
we don't get everything we want but it's
okay this wedding but yeah whatever okay
so i think one of the most beautiful
things that has come out of this is the
real deal friendship that you guys have
built friendship is over there she
doesn't like hot tamales i'm very
offended by this i'm judging me
but yes no we do we became best friends
i know it's crazy right we used to we
lived together we drove to work together
we shared a dream yeah we took her name
off hers and we just stuck it on mine
and we were like we're in here now we
both we'll both be in here please set
our costumes in this trailer they need
to get us ready in there and everyone's
like literally walking like this but can
we use them like no we do it in here now
we do touches in the make nope we're
doing it in kayla's trailer thank you so
much we'll be in there today as we're
like chomping on snacks and oh my god
one little thing i have to say to you i
root for this one like nobody's business
like i ride for this one right here so i
like i like her you already because you
take care of her
she's a good one yeah did you have to
approve of the fella
[Laughter]
actually it was weird she was like the
last one to meet him and i was dead
about it but you know what it's what
it's really interesting and she said
this from the beginning
she i mean i
i knew when she knew
anytime you know like any time anything
in our life though we're very on the
same wavelength and so we're so it's
when you're best friends with someone
when you're truly best friends and you
love them that deeply you're so
interconnected and when i met him i was
one of the last to meet him i met him
and i was like i feel like i've known
you forever i feel like you've been here
and he loves her like nobody's business
and that's all that matters to me enough
said
i love it